hey you guys
so this is my inaugural episode of my
new series which is going to be called
flickers of fear
it's kind of like a companion series i
guess to my tomes of terror where i
review
uh you know horror books i figured that
we really needed to do
more movie reviews just because i have
so many ones that you guys have sent and
i have so many ones like in
that have been recommended and i really
need to get to them all
and you know tom and i together just
doing one old movie a week and then a
couple of new ones
just wasn't really cutting it i felt
like i was really getting behind
and i didn't really want to have to get
him involved in stuff that
you know or watching some movies that he
wasn't really all that interested in
because you know i like a lot of
movies that he's not really into
particularly in the horror genre
so i was like well instead of doing the
witching hour show which i used to do on
thursdays um
i think i'll kind of discontinue that at
least as a weekly enterprise
and um i'll start doing a couple of
movie reviews every week just so i can
get caught up on all of the you know the
backlog of movies that i want to see and
that like i said that you guys have
since
you know so that's what i decided to do
i think i'm gonna post these on thursday
and uh
saturdays probably the thursday one will
be like a newer film just like we would
do on the matinee
and the saturday one is probably gonna
be an older film you know anywhere from
[ __ ] silent films into you know the 80s
or 90s or whatever
so that's kind of how i'm going to do it
i'm not going to have any particular
you know order the way i do them or
anything it's just kind of whatever
old movie and whatever new movie i
watched that week and felt like talking
about so that's pretty much
how it's going to be from here on out so
for my first one
i decided to do this one that a lot of
people have recommended to me
and that i had actually been wanting to
see for quite a while
but i had just never kind of sat down
and watched it because you know it's
kind of long and it's kind of a time
commitment but i had really really been
wanting to see it so finally finally
i sat down one afternoon and just sat
there and watched it
and that is the 2018 the house that jack
built directed by lars von trier
now i don't know how familiar you guys
are with the work of lars von trier he's
kind of you know i'm in cinema circles
he's actually very well known
as sort of a provocateur i guess
a lot of his movies are very
controversial and cause like a lot of
polarized
sort of reactions to them which is kind
of what he's going for he's danish by
the way
i'm not a huge uh expert on his stuff
i have seen three or four of his movies
now i'm thinking about it i saw dogville
which i loved i saw antichrist which i
also loved uh it wasn't as shocking as i
was expecting i guess
because it had so much of a reputation
around it
and then i saw it probably a year or two
after it came out on dvd
and i was like you know that i thought
it was a beautiful movie
it's and it did have some shocking
scenes in it but i didn't find it as
shocking as maybe some people i don't
know if that's just because i'm jaded or
whatever
um and i've also seen dancer in the dark
i might have seen melancholia but i kind
of doubt it
because i'm sure i would have remembered
it so i've seen three of his other
movies so i kind of know
and i've liked them so i kind of know
what i'm in for i know that
a lot of his films are just intended to
provoke a particular reaction
uh whether that's to make people angry
or to make people outraged or just to be
shocking or violent for the sake of it
which is kind of a simplistic way of
going about it but you know
that's kind of his deal and uh he just
doesn't really like i mean
from what i can understand very famously
when he won i believe he won the palm
door for
uh for dancer in the dark and he was
kind of mad about it because he was like
well that means that
i had to get this many votes and i don't
think that he really likes to be
popular or likes to make movies that are
seen to be popular that a lot of people
he like you know that a lot of people
like i think he
is happier when he's being provocative
you know what i mean when he's being
shocking i think if he thinks too many
people like it then that means that it
was too safe or something like that so
with all that context i kind of go into
the house that jack built which is
nominally a horror movie um i guess you
could call it a horror movie it's kind
of you know it follows a serial killer
and there's a lot of uh really intense
gore
and violence in it that said i'm not
really sure i've read like
a kind of a panoply of reviews about it
and some of them kind of got this and
some of them not to my mind as i was
watching it
just maybe am i weird i don't know i
thought it was
hilarious it's a black comedy further
than that
i think it's a black comedy where lars
von trier
is essentially making fun of himself
making fun of his own pretensions you
know in in a way that it's it's very
you know i think that he has a
reputation for being very egotistical
and self-aggrandizing
but in this one it seems like he's
lampooning that and to me it seemed
that was kind of obviously what he was
going for maybe everybody didn't get
that reading out of it but to me
that's very much what it seemed like i
mean to me it seemed like
it's very dark and gruesome but it's
also very very very funny
and you can tell that the main character
jack played by matt dillon
is not supposed to be a hero or an
anti-hero you're not supposed to like
him you're supposed to
the movie is kind of making fun of him
in a way
um at least that's how i interpreted it
so i actually have to say this i don't
know this might be
i'd have to see dogville and antichrist
and stuff like that again
but this might be my favorite um of all
the lars von trier films that i have
seen
it looks beautiful it's hilarious you
know the gore
is disturbing but i didn't find it
that shocking i mean you know i i watch
a lot of horror movies so it
really takes a lot before i'm just like
oh man let's not go there
so this one now i do the the version
that i saw is actually on hulu at the
moment
so i assume that this is the edited
version because there
was um you know a director's cut that
was that was what was shown at can
and uh that was actually shown i think
for one night like an unlimited
theatrical release back in 2018 when
this came out
you know so i so i think that some
people are saying that that one was like
super gruesome and that one was
just way over the top but from my
understanding i don't think a great deal
of it was taken out
i think there were you know uh maybe a
few seconds here like trimmed here there
in some of the murder scenes
particularly um i think the one
incident that had to do with uh the girl
jacqueline who he
called simple um you know and him
cutting her breasts off
i think they showed more of that in the
uh director's cut
so like i said i'm assuming that the one
on hulu is not the director's cut
so you know your mileage maybe maybe it
is like way way
way more gruesome but from what i
understand they didn't take a great deal
of it out even if they
i don't know i just don't think the
violence uh against
you know the the violence in the movie
probably wouldn't have bothered me
because like i said it takes a really
really lot
of violence in a movie before i'm just
like oh man i can't watch that
i'm actually more you know as most of
you know i'm actually a lot more
sensitive to
uh you know simulated violence again
well real violence obviously that goes
without saying but simulated violence in
movies against animals
so i will say that the most memorably
upsetting scene and this one involved a
duckling and if you've seen it you know
what i'm talking about
it was so realistic that that was the
only
that was the only scene in the movie
where i was just like ah bro
did you really have to show that i mean
you know what i mean i know it was
fake well i hope it was fake it didn't
look fake i will say that it was very
realistic and that was kind of the only
scene that really
upset me so i don't know what that says
about me but you know so what is this
movie about
it it does have sort of a narrative to
it but as with most of his other films
you know it's very experimental some
people say like arty farty which it is
but i think it's also it's still pretty
accessible
i think um you know maybe not to like
just a general audience but
you know to people who are more into
cinema and stuff like that i don't think
it's
all that off-putting i mean at least
from my point of view i don't know like
i say i'm just
because i'm into horror movies so maybe
it doesn't bother me as much so
as i said matt dillon plays a serial
killer only
uh only known as jack and he is
basically telling about
five incidents over his
12-year killing spree because apparently
he killed
uh 60 people you know in the 70s and 80s
so he is telling about five random
incidents that he chose from his back
catalog i suppose
and he's telling this to what is clearly
an old man
you only hear the voice at first uh the
voice is bruno gans by the way who was
also in
nosferatu the 1979 one who he only calls
verge
but as it goes on it becomes very um
blindingly obvious
that this is the meta text of this if
you want to
call it that the overarching story of
this is
dante's divine comedy where
virgil is you know leading dante down
into
the underworld uh you know down the nine
levels of hell or whatever
so that's kind of so keep that in mind
while you're watching this like i said
it's not like he's subtle about it or
anything like that i mean
if you know anything anything about
classical literature
you know or anything like that then uh
then it will
be pretty obvious like right from the
outset what's going on
so essentially they're going down the
nine circles of hell
and matt dillon is or you know jack
obviously is telling virgil
about all of these different uh murders
that he committed
and there then they are portrayed the
interesting thing about this and the
reason why i say that i think
maybe uh lars von trier is
poking fun at himself is that
it seemed to me very much that the jack
character
was meant to be i mean i'm not saying
that lars ron trier is a serial killer
obviously
but i think he was written as the
director's sort of avatar
and the fact that you have virgil
these discussions that they have that
you have virgil kind of
pricking holes in jack's pretensions
i think is the director making fun of
himself
making fun of some you know some of his
views some of the things that he said
so so i really liked that about it and i
thought it was like really interesting
and so because you know as i said he's
kind of a controversial figure
uh he was actually banned from the
canned festival for some
questionable comments he made um you
know there's there's been all kinds of
allegations swirling around
him being you know misogynistic you know
some sexual assault type or
sexual harassment type stuff um you know
all that kind of stuff
so i think that you know him being this
controversial figure and
making these pieces of art that are
deliberately meant to provoke you
i think that he's kind of having a
having fun with it almost and i kind of
dug that
i mean i should mention too that when
this was shown
at the cannes festival and as i said he
had been banned from the canned festival
so
they let him show it but he couldn't
show it like in the competition you know
like he couldn't get a prize for
anything this this will give you an idea
is that at the can screening about a
hundred people got up and walked out
uh you know because they just couldn't
take it they were disgusted
and they thought it was vile but after
the movie was over he
lars von trier got a 10-minute standing
ovation so
that should tell you the kind of [ __ ]
that you're dealing with here and pretty
much like
i think most of his films uh engender
that kind of a reaction
whether because the thing about it is i
i feel like there's some kind of
a debate to be had over whether
he intentionally shocks people just for
the sake of shocking them which i think
he does
now i think that if that's all your art
does
i'm not saying you shouldn't do it or or
it should be banned or anything like
that i just don't know if it
you know would have anything more to say
if that's all that you're doing but i
don't think that's the case with lars
von trier yes i do think that he's
deliberately trying to provoke a
reaction with his work yes i do think
that he's deliberately trying to be
shocking and trying to upset people on
purpose
but i do think that he's doing it
for a reason i don't think he's just
doing it because he can
or you know you know what i mean he
definitely does seem like he has
something to say as weird as
whatever as what that is so i definitely
would argue that
yes this has some vile imagery in it but
i do think it
serves a purpose you know what i'm
saying i don't think it's shocking just
for
the sake of it like i said i'm not a
huge um
you know expert on his work or anything
like that but i have seen some of his
films and i do know of his reputation
somewhat so the fact that he
made a movie like this i i just found it
really really interesting and like i
said it's really beautiful to look at
it's shot really cool and everything
like that
so uh so you go through these incidents
the first incident
jack who is an engineer but he had
actually i guess he says in there that
he had actually wanted to be an
architect so
the the whole overarching narrative of
the house that jack built
being that he keeps coming back to he
had bought this plot of
land because he had an inheritance from
his parents we don't know presumably but
he had this big inheritance so we didn't
really need to
you know work or he could kind of do
what he wanted to a large extent
so he had bought this piece of land and
spent all these years working on his
perfect house and they show him like
working on the models
but then it it kept happening that he
would
build it partly and then it just wasn't
coming out the way he wanted so he would
like bulldoze it and then he would start
over so like over the years
it's become kind of like this albatross
that's hung around his neck where it's
like every time he
gets the house partially built something
happens just like i don't like it and
then he has to you know bulldoze it and
start over
so that's kind of all going on in the
background while he's talking about
these
incidents and like i said the movie is
in kind of five parts which are called
incidents and then there's
uh a six part which is like epilogue and
it's called catabosis
if i'm pronouncing that right which is
like a greek word and it means like
descent
what does it mean descent toward the
darkness or some or ascent toward the
light i can't remember but it's
something like that so you know what i
mean it's it's
you know going along with the whole uh
you know divine comedy theme
so in the first incident which stars uma
thurman by the way
uh jack is driving his little red murder
van down
uh kind of a lonely road and he comes
across um thurman's character
and uh her car has broken down or she's
got a flat tire something like that and
her jack is broken
so first she asked him to borrow his
jack and which his name is jack too
which is kind of funny
and he doesn't have one so basically
he's like well i can drive you to this
dude he's a blacksmith he's like five
miles up the road he can fix the jack
for you and then
you can fix the car yourself like i
don't have time for this [ __ ] or
whatever now while they're driving
to the blacksmith their pretty much
entire discussion which is mostly just
her talking
is her talking about wow this is like
the perfect situation
for you to be a serial killer and you to
murder me and like leave my body out
here in the woods and nobody would ever
find me and all this other kind of stuff
and the funny thing about it is that for
a long time
she keeps going on like that and he
doesn't do anything like he doesn't kill
her
he takes her to the blacksmith they get
the jack fixed he drives her back to her
car
you know she then the jack breaks again
and uh you know so they have to go back
and forth a few times and she
is super super annoying so finally she
just keeps sort of taunting him saying
oh you know you couldn't be a serial
killer you too much of a wimp or
something like that and finally he just
like you know crushes her face in with
the jack
and then puts her in the freezer that he
keeps for the purpose
so that's like the first incident now
the second incident
um he goes to this woman's house and
again it's kind of
remote it's like out in the country and
he gives her he goes to the door and he
gives her this cockamamie story about
being a cop
she doesn't believe it um and then
he finally it's just this really funny
like awkward
situation because she's obviously like
really distrustful but he just like
keeps their means yeah i'm a cop and my
i don't have my badge because it's at
the silversmith and it's being shined up
and stuff and she's just like what the
[ __ ] are you even talking about so
finally he's like oh okay well
you know that's good that's good that
you didn't let me in um i'm actually not
a cop i'm an insurance agent
um because she's he sees something on
her wall that uh that says that her
husband was uh
died in the line of duty or something
like that and uh he's like i'm you know
i'm an insurance agent i could get you
like all this
like double your pension and stuff and
finally finally she lets him in
and he ends up uh killing her and the
thing that happens in this one
that is also very you know darkly
hilarious
is that at this point he's telling
virgil
that he has really bad ocd and that
during this particular murder
he you know he killed the woman and then
he cleaned everything up
and he put her in the van or behind the
van at first i'll get into that in a
minute
but then even though he he heard like
police sirens coming in the distance he
kept having
these recurring visions like he would go
out and sit in the van like and get
ready to go
and then he would have these visions
that oh my god there was this like this
puddle of blood like underneath the
carpet or there was like a behind a
picture or something like that he's like
i gotta go back in and check
so he kept doing that like so much so
that the cops actually got there
and he had to tell them like this lame
ass story
um you know and the cops were kind of
dumb and they believed him and then it
ended up that he had the body of the
woman like tied behind
the truck like on a rope and then it
left this blood trail like all the way
to his body storage
facility but then rain came and washed
it away which
made him feel like you know maybe i
don't know if he necessarily said
something like you know that
that means god says it's okay because
that was like divine intervention that's
like so i didn't get caught
one theme of this movie like through all
these incidents
and you have to understand too that
these incidents are being told from his
point of view so
i was assuming that he was an unreliable
narrator he was making himself
look better and making his victims
and the cops look dumb and incompetent
you know what i'm saying so
it was a very self-aggrandizing
narrative because
as you go through the movie it seems
very clear that jack
has a philosophy that his
murders are akin to great
art and so there's a lot of discussions
between him and virgil
him trying to justify the murders that
he's
done and as i said being very
self-aggrandizing
and arguing for for murder as an
art form you know what i mean and like i
said that sounds ridiculous but that's
because it
is this is a dark comedy and i think
that's kind of what he was going for and
like i said he's not supposed to be
a heroic character or even an
anti-heroic character he's supposed to
be
an idiot who thinks these ridiculous
things
who doesn't realize that he's an idiot
that thinks ridiculous things i mean
that was what i got out of it
that to me it seemed very obvious that
that's what the character was supposed
to be
i mean obviously he was kind of like a
[ __ ] and he
thought all these stupid things but he
thought he was this great
artist who was saying something really
profound like with his murders
he even after the second murder he
decides he needs
like a real like a like a brand or like
a name for himself so he starts calling
himself mr sophistication for [ __ ]
sake so then
you have uh this other incident the
third one
which uh seems like this one is uh
pretty upsetting too
i'm gonna say uh this is one where i
guess it was a woman he was dating
and uh she had two kids who are just
called george and then the other one's
called grumpy i don't think they ever
say what his name is that's just what
the mom calls him
and he takes them out out hunting and uh
is
showing them how to use shotguns or
whatever and um not surprisingly ends up
blowing them all away uh so if you don't
want to see
little kids getting shot then uh maybe
you might want to avoid this
like i said also if you don't want to
see something really bad happening to a
duckling
uh you might want to not want to watch
this either some i'm not i'm not going
to lie some of the [ __ ] in this is kind
of
upsetting it is kind of hard to watch um
so if you're
kind of sensitive to that kind of thing
it's i wouldn't advise it because
this movie is supposed to upset you i
mean that's
essentially what it is so if you don't
want to be upset then
don't watch it that's all i'm saying so
so yeah so there was that and then so he
kills the mom and the two
little boys and kind of poses them
and then uh the fourth incident which
probably is the one that got
i feel like that was the one that got
the most flack about being misogynistic
and everything but as i said
you know because jack says some very
like boldly
misogynistic things during this
particular incident you know like oh
you know men are born guilty and women
are always victims it's so much easier
and he just says
stuff like this to this girlfriend that
he has that he's been
emotionally and presumably physically
abusing as well
um and as i said he ends up cutting her
boobs off is what he ends up doing and
he takes one of the boobs and like puts
it under the
windshield of the police car that's
nearby
that's and again that's another kind of
thread running through this is that
he almost seems like somebody you know
somebody in higher authority wanted me
to do this because
i was doing these things out in plain
sight and i there were no consequences
like i was just getting away with stuff
even when i tried to get caught nobody
could catch me
so it's almost kind of like he thought
that he had the divine right to do it
somehow i don't think he uses those
words but i think that that's
kind of what his line of thinking was in
the fifth incident
this is supposed to be his kind of uh
masterwork i guess he has kidnapped
all of these guys and by this point he
has like a whole [ __ ] ton of
frozen bodies like in his freezer but he
now he has he's kidnapped a bunch of
dudes and he has and they're alive in
there
and he wants to put them he has them all
tied to this
kind of you know post or whatever and he
wants to
shoot them all through the head with
using one bullet
so then there's this almost farcical
kind of thing where he
he thinks that he bought a box of
ammunition that was full metal jacket
because that was the only thing that
would go through all of the heads
and then he opens the box and one of the
victims like larry says that's
that one's not a full metal jacket they
gave you the wrong thing and then he has
to go back to the gun store and it's
just like this ridiculous
ridiculous scene and i don't know it's
like maybe i'm a bad person but like to
me that was just so
so funny i mean it was just like i said
it's
black humor i mean it's very very very
dark humor but
i don't know i i kind of like that so i
just thought it was really funny
so that was the fifth incident and that
is when
uh he met up with virgil uh who
is played by bruno gans as i said
earlier and he actually turns up in the
freezer and he says hey i've been
watching you all this time and
they essentially are going to go down to
the underworld and this
that's kind of when he's going to tell
him all the stuff that he's been telling
him so this whole movie is essentially a
flashback now
one thing they actually do kind of go
back to the whole house metaphor because
it does turn out that
because he couldn't build a regular
house and he kept messing it up and he
kept having to
start over um basically he's like oh no
my masterwork now i just figured it out
is i'm going to build a house out of all
these frozen corpses that i had in my so
he does that so he builds this house
when the cops finally come he runs in
there and that's when he goes down into
the underworld
so then during the epilogue which is
gorgeous i mean it looks like i just
love
the way the epilogue is shot it looks
like those old you know medieval
paintings and woodcuts and stuff just
the way it's just the cinematography is
just
you know amazing in it so they go down
like through all these circles and
all this stuff is like all these
tableaus are recreated it's really
really cool
and uh so while they're going down there
finally
you know and he's been telling virgil
the [ __ ] all along and then finally
virgil tells them you know there's they
come to this broken bridge
you know over this the abyss of hell
you're presuming
and um he's like so you know where does
that go over there like
past you know the broken part of the
bridge he's like oh yeah well it used to
be
you know you used to be able to get
across the bridge that's like the
stairway to heaven over there
essentially so jack is kind of you know
arrogant to the end
jack is kind of like well has anybody
ever tried to climb around these
rock walls and gotten over there like to
the other side like to
because i think i should go to heaven
because i'm such an amazing artist look
at all the
profound work that i produced and so
virgil is basically like well you can
try it if you want to
and he does try it and uh
it doesn't go so well but yeah so as i
said this is
uh definitely not a movie for everybody
uh it is if you like arty farty kind of
cinema or if you like like really really
weird
horror films or really really really
gruesome
dark comedies uh this might be your jam
uh if you liked some of his other movies
then probably you should check this one
out i think this one is probably my
favorite one at least
um of the ones that i've seen and like i
said that's not
all that many but it just has such a
funny it has a beautiful look to it
um i love all the dante's inferno stuff
i love the humor of it it was just so
i mean some of this stuff and it was
just so absurd to me it was just
i don't know it just really really made
me laugh like a whole bunch of times
so like i said maybe that makes me a bad
person i don't know
if you think and like i said just a
little bit of a content warning the
violence is
quite gruesome there is a very very
upsetting scene involving a duckling
which
like you know i've seen you can do
whatever you want
to humans in movies like you know what i
mean uh you know as long as it's fake
obviously i don't want to see real [ __ ]
but don't do something to animals man
even if it's fake it really really
bothers me and uh this one really but so
weirdly like all this all the violence
against humans like you like shooting
little kids and stuff like that in the
movie it's like that didn't really
bother me as much have kind of bothered
me but not that much
but the scene with the duckling i was
just kind of like oh no oh
and i just i just didn't want to watch
it but uh yeah so if that's going to
upset you just
i'm just warning you right now that
that's where it is but overall
i actually really really loved this
movie so
it's one of those things like your
mileage may vary um all of his movies
are kind of like that they're either
kind of love them or hate them
but i just thought it was a very very
funny it's a little long i will say that
um it's about two and a half hours two
hours 32 minutes something like that
um it didn't seem that long to me but i
can see how some people might think that
it gets too bogged down in all of his
kind of philosophical discussions
about the nature of art and icons
and uh there's a whole sequence where he
talks about how good uh
you know evil people like hitler and
stuff like that were at
producing art because you know they
produce so much death and so much iconic
imagery
so there's a lot of that in there so
there's like a lot of philosophical
waffling but as i said i think that's
kind of all in service
to lars von trier you know taking the
wind out of his own sails a little bit
poking fun at himself a little bit
because in that sequence
where they're talking about like nazi
concentration camps and they're talking
about all the
you know all these other horrific
tragedies and uh
you know holocausts and things he also
inserts images from his own former
movies so it's almost kind of like he's
trying to
link his own work with that but also
like
making fun of the fact that he's doing
that you know if that makes any sense
i'm not really sure uh so this is on
hulu right now like i said i'm pretty
sure it's not the unrated version it's
the r-rated version
i don't know exactly how much
was cut out of the r-rated version i
imagine it was just
uh you know a few seconds trimmed here
and there like so it wasn't
excessively violent but this still is
pretty violent and pretty um
you know upsetting if you're uh not
gonna like that kind of thing
but i don't know i i really dug it i i
thought it was
pretty entertaining in a bizarre way
check it out if that's the kind of thing
that you're into
and um i'll see you on the next one bye